je viens de prendre en main le nouveau
Samsung Galaxy Boop 3 ultra un nouvel
ordi qui vient d'arriver dans la gamme
Galaxy book souvenez-vous l'année
dernière on avait Galaxy book 2 book 2
Pro book 360 book 3 pro 360 et viens
d'arriver avec la gamme boom 3 et bien
le plus gros le ultra qui permettra
d'aller beaucoup plus loin avec une
carte graphique dédiée on va avoir de la
RTX 45 50 sur la version i7 et derrière
TX 40 70 sur la version 1.9 donc si vous
voulez venir jouer dessus si vous voulez
utiliser pour la productivité c'est un
ordi qui est vraiment passe partout et
en plus de ça c'est super intéressant
c'est que vous avez ici un très grand
écran de 16 pouces on se parle ici d'une
dalle dynamique AMOLED 2x et la grosse
nouveauté qui est intéressant sur la
série book3 par rapport à la série book
2 c'est qu'on passe d'un 16/9 à 16
dixième donc on gagne un petit peu au
niveau de l'espace utile sur l'écran le
cœur l'écosystème c'est bien évidemment
votre Smartphone vous prenez vos photos
avec votre Galaxy S23 ultra vous avez
des clichés de dingue vous venez les
mettre directement ici avec Witcher vous
venez les éditer directement avec
Lightroom bref c'est un outil qui est
vraiment la plus pour les créatifs pour
ceux qui veulent du matériel exigeant un
prix quand même relativement élevé on en
reparlera bientôt sur Youtube un peu
partout donc dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires